I looked at these people that are Ultra
famous and I was like huh well I'd still
rather be anonymous I want to be rich
and unknown they've got all these
stalkers and Weirdos when you get
exposed to 10 million people if you
figure one percent of people are crazy
you got a hundred thousand weirdos it's
a lot of weirdos I go to have dinner
with a friend of mine he gets like
weirdos to come to his house and all
that kind of stuff and I was like how do
you deal with this how is this worth it
you know I mean like tell me on this
because I just was like I'm not Soul so
he sat me down he was like dude if a
couple weird letters every day or every
week is the price I have to pay for the
impact I want to have pay that price any
day of the week and twice on Sunday
there was just like this pause when he
said it I just felt like it hit me God
I'm being such a pansy I realized that
for me to have the impact that I wanted
to have if I claimed which I do if I
want to make real business education
available to everyone then I need to
match my actions to that that's the
price I have to pay for make the impact
I want to have then it's a price that
I'm willing to pay